well let's return to our breaking news
this lunchtime the blackpool nhs trust
has declared an internal critical
incident due to omicron and staff
shortages
skies inzamam rasheed is in blackpool
for us hello to you indy uh blackpool
the latest nhs trust what are you
hearing
that's right sally look this hospital is
already incredibly busy they are
struggling because of demand not only on
staff but also an increased number of
patients with kovid 19 in particular
omicron and as a result we can see this
board behind me has actually been
flashing uh all um afternoon since we've
been here a lot of red signs saying that
they are struggling with waiting times
for people coming in and also advising
that only critically ill patients come
to the hospital
as well i'll just give you a bit more
detail of we've heard from the hospital
in the last half an hour or so from the
foundation trust and we're here
at the blackpool victoria hospital as i
said has been struggling what they've
said is that because of pressures the
trust is under we have made the decision
to declare an internal critical incident
which means staff across the trust will
be working together today to take
actions immediately to attempt to
alleviate the pressures we are under
including stepping down some non-urgent
activity in order to deliver all of the
things we can and need to do to provide
the very best care if possible now that
was natalie hudson the chief operating
officer at blackpool teaching hospitals
and now what she's also been saying is
that the um the pressures have been
exacerbated by rapidly rising rates of
covet 19 in our communities and the
rising rates of admissions to hospitals
which is creating those further
pressures around discharge we've seen
that that is an issue at the hospital
here in blackpool but also the other
hospitals that fall under this trust as
well that includes the fleetwood uh
hospital clifton hospital morecambe bay
westmoreland general hospital the royal
lancaster infirmary and furnace general
as well now this comes after
um the more com bay university hospitals
trust also said that they were going
into a critical uh incident level aaron
cummings the chief executive executive
there confirmed uh in a statement that
the trusted declared that internal
critical incident and he'd actually said
on twitter that sadly despite everyone's
best efforts many of our patients are
still receiving a level of care and
experience that falls below the level of
standards we would like he also said
that non-urgent operations and
procedures would be suspended it seems
that these hospitals took an initial
step
of banning visitors coming to the
hospital unless there were extreme
circumstances we've also seen that case
happen at another lancashire trust as
well which looks after um the royal
preston hospital and a chorley hospital
as well i've been in discussions with
them this afternoon they are reviewing
their current situation to see if they
need to declare an internal
critical incident level as well but
clearly lancashire as a county
struggling with covet cases with the
number of patients coming into hospital
and also that added pressure of staff
catching kovid 19 and as a result
they're having to declare these
incidents sally